[موسيقى]
هي الزهره المفضله لدى الفرنسيين ومع ذلك
لا نجيب الكثير منها في باقاتنا لانها
ببساطه بكثره في افريقيا وامريكا
اللاتينيه الورود الفرنسيه علامه فاخره
بامتياز لا يمكن نحن نتحدث عنها الا ان
نقصدها
في العالم باسره هنا لا يتم فقط
من الورود البيضاء الكبيره جدا سنقوم
بطريقه تسمح لنا بالحصول على ورده كبيره
متماسكه في الوقت نفسه انتم تحضرون الان
عمليه تلقيح ورده ستعطينا عده ورود صغيره
هذه الطريقه علمتني اياها جدتي حين كنت
صغيرا ذا عشر سنوات
بتهجينها مباشره بالاصابع هكذا من خلال
وضع الكثير من حبوب اللقاح
هوايه الاجداد التي بدات مع الجد الاكبر
عام
1850 في مدينه ليو عشق الهروب انتقل من
جيل الى جيل لدى هذه العائله التي انتقلت
الى العيش في جنوب فرنسا في الخمسينيات
وقامت حينها ماري لويس جده الشهيره باداره
المؤسسه العائليه ومواصله مشوار انتاج
الالاف من الورود المختلفه
سونيا
جميع الخصائص التي قد تبحث عنها في الورود
مع انتاجها لورده السلام ذاع الصوت
العائله في جميع انحاء العالم
واستمر نجاحها اكثر مع ابداءها لورود
اصليه تحمل اسماء العديد من المشاهير
الذين كان لكل منهم شرف اختيار ورده معينه
ووضع اسمائهم عليها
ابداع العائله لم يتوقف عند هذا الحد كل
سنه تخصص الشركه اكثر من مليون يورو للبحث
والتطوير هذا الصباح يتم اختيار انواع
جديده من الورود
لابد ان تكون حقيقيه هذا مثلا احمر امريكي
وهذا احمر اوروبي
كلما كانت كبيره كانت جيده واذا كانت لها
رائحه زكيه فذلك يجعل منها اجمل الورود
لا نبتعد عن الريفيرا الفرنسيه نتوجه الان
الى مدينه جغراس العاصمه العالميه للعطور
الورود من
دونش مكانه خاصه هنا
روائح عطور علامه الديار
المئات من العطور ذات الصيت العالمي نواه
عمله هي الورود
تسلم حجر الاساسي
من الورق في هذه القاروره مثلا توجد عشرات
الكيلو غرامات من بتلات الازهار
تتم عمليه هنا بعد قطف الازهار خلال شهر
مايو حيث يكون الاستخلاص باستخدام
المذيبات لاستخراج الزيوت العطريه الحساسه
التي لا تحتمل درجات الحراره العاليه
وتنتج عنها زيوت المركزه
والحصول على الزيت المركزي لابد من مزج
هذا المستخلص مع الكحول نبدا بترشيح ثم
نقوم بتركيز
لابد ان يكون الزيت المركز قابل للذوبان
في الكحول حتى تكون الرائحه جديه تماما في
العطر في النهايه
600 كيلو متر شمالا وفي مدينه بخوفا
بالضبط تزرع الورود بكثره ايضا
من الازهار الذي يعود للعصور الوسطى
استخداماته متعدده قد تصل حتى الى اطباقنا
في متجر كارلا نجده في قاروره متنوعه
لكنها تخصص هذه السيده يتمثل في صناعه
مربى الورد
انه الكنز يؤكل مع شرائح الكبد الطازج او
مع الجبن الطري المخمر
بقطفي وترتيب 300 كيلوغرام من بتلات
الورود قبل تجميدها منذ متى تشتمين هذه
الرائحه منذ 27 سنه 27 سنه اجل كاجمل ما
يكون الاستنشاق
تها بالحرفه الى ابنها يتم غمس بتلات
الورود في العسل المختار بعنايه مع الحفاظ
على التوازن المناسب حتى لا يكون حلوا
كثيرا لابد من العثور على المذاق الوسط
حتى طعمه
نعم هل تخبرونكيف
انه سر
يتم تسخين البتلات والعسل وفق الطريقه
القديمه مع اضافه الليمون والماء والسكر
حب كارلا للورود لا ينضب ابدا
جميع الحدود يفضلها الفرنسيون على ازهار
اخرى تعد الورود من اكثر المبيعات في
فرنسا يتم تزيينها ضمن اكثر من 22 مليون
باقه كل سنه
[موسيقى]